great ideas are never going to interrupt
you they have to be pursued and you if
you don't pursue them you're going to
get what everybody else has which is all
this fear all this uncertainty all this
stuff it won't work because everybody's
focused on what won't work what can't
happen why because they're afraid
they're afraid to fail they're afraid to
try and feel like they're not enough so
you gotta stand guard of that mind by
feeding your mind you know jim rohn used
to say to me success leaves clues if you
want thing to get better you got to get
better if you want things to change you
got to change but you got to do it
deliberately and consciously and he used
to say to me constantly said tony you've
got to constantly find a way to feed
that mind something that's got strategy
in it philosophy something that's going
to improve the quality of your life
and if you really learn it
you can help the people you love with
the things you learn
and so i got hooked and so i decided i'm
going to read a book a day i took a
speed reading course and i didn't read a
book a day but i read 700 books over the
period of seven years all in the area of
philosophy physiology emotion the things
to me that mattered most and what i
really try to do is each day try to use
something i learned not just read not
just let my
learning lead to knowledge you know jim
used to say if you let you learn to lead
in knowledge you become a fool
if you let you learn lead to action
that's when your life changes so i
started being aware of who was saying
what what i was taking in you know jim
used to say you know success leaves
clues if someone's successful they're
not lucky they're doing something
different than you figure out what
they're doing different he said the
first thing is find out what they're
reading
he said because he said i remember he
sent me something funny he said find out
what poor people read and don't read it
and we said poor he didn't just mean
financially poor he meant people that
were unhappy people that were had no
sense of meaning in their life people
that were financially strapped because
they weren't managing to add value to
other people people that found
themselves not taking your relationships
their body poor isn't just money wealth
isn't just money it's emotional
spiritual everything he said so find out
what successful people do what wealthy
people read what happy people and read
that
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how to
raise our standards with tony robbins
enjoy
rule number two decide what to focus on
every moment of your life you're
answering three questions first question
is what are you going to focus on
so the most powerful decision we make
most of us don't make it consciously is
what are we going to focus on
we don't focus on everything we focus on
a small number of things and that's what
we experience in life
because you could be focusing right now
on the blood rushing through your left
ear or the touch of your clothes against
your skin but you don't
most of what your brain does is distort
delete and generalize it makes life
simple
and the problem is you distort delete
and generalize you miss a lot of your
life
and focus right down equals feeling
whatever you focus on you're going to
feel even if it's not true if i asked
you there are two things you could focus
on what you have or what's missing which
one do you spend more time focusing on
if your brain is constantly focusing
what's missing how can you ever sustain
happiness no matter how successful you
become it is impossible what happens
when you focus on what you have you feel
alive you feel no scarcity you feel joy
how many of you have lots of things in
your life that if you focused on it you
could feel grateful for you could feel
excited about how many got lots of
things like this now say i
but it doesn't exist unless you focus on
and we all have patterns of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
can control or what you can't control
what's outside your control what is
someone gonna feel is constantly focused
on what's missing and what they can't
control
sad frustrated angry depressed
so why are they still depressed because
they are still focusing on what's
missing
and they're focused on what they can't
control and i'll add one more do you
tend to focus more on things from the
past
the present or the future we all do all
three but if you're going to spend your
predominant time and you want enjoyment
it's the present if you want to be
create a great life it's the future so
it's a balance between the present and
future
these three patterns alone can change
your whole life the second question is
what does this mean because the minute
you focus on something you have to give
it a meaning is this the end or the
beginning
is god punishing me that's why this
problem happened
is god challenging me
or is this problem a gift from god see
if you think it's the end of a
relationship
are you going to feel the same way act
the same ways if you think it's the
beginning of a relationship yes or no
no
the meaning changes the answer to the
third question which is what am i going
to do
because meaning equals emotion
whatever you give a meaning you're gonna
have a feeling if you think god is
punishing you you're gonna have a very
different feeling from that meaning then
you think god is challenging you or this
problem is a gift from god these three
questions are happening every moment of
your life
and if you're not careful they take
control of you
we
are the people that create the quality
of our lives we got to change what's
going on here and here rule number three
expand your identity why is identity so
important for us to shape a positive
powerful identity well first of all so
everybody understands what i mean by
identity is we all have a way of
identifying ourselves we have a way of
labeling ourselves
so
most of us came up with our labels based
on how we behaved but really smart
people can do stupid things really nice
people can be mean mean people can be
nice and so if you judge yourself too
soon and most people's identity their
labels for themselves who they think
they are has been based on their past
and often many years ago and so they
don't update it so the the metaphor i'd
give for identity is like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals
so if you like if you took a temperature
in the room and said 68 degrees is my
comfort zone physically emotionally
financially i want more in my
relationship i want more physically
energy-wise i want more financially in
my career but this is what i'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa whoa
you're a 68 degree or what the hell are
you doing we've all experienced that all
of a sudden you go i'm not going to live
like this anymore i'm not going to be in
this relationship i'm not going to be
fat like this
boom and you get this drive and you
start to change but what most people
don't understand
is it happens on the upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing it you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 degrees financially
emotionally spiritually whatever the
metaphor is and then what happens you're
gonna say hey you're bringing us what
the hell do you think you are you're not
a 98 degree
right get back to 68 and if nothing else
the heaters stop you lose your drive and
that'll drift you back and not enough
the air conditioning can kick on you
start to kind of sabotage yourself till
you get back to your comfort zone
so unless you expand your identity
change is temporary it's like when
someone says to me i've stopped smoking
it's been eight days
i go
and i say why are you counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time like if i went to
somebody and and i said to you hey you
know
louis you want a cigarette you're not
going to say what brand is it you know
no
i'm not a smoker notice how people i'm
not one of those that's not my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look lance
armstrong was a mixed identity now in
the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win so when he was told he had
cancer
in his lungs in his brain and in his
testicles and he rides a bike
and he's going to die
his answer was no i'm a champion i find
the way i will find the answer and he
did now unfortunately he bent the rules
around the sport and it kind of ruined
his reputation obviously but that
mentality his identity is why he
survived other people told they have
cancer and they're like it's over they
give up they start arranging their
affairs and so that psychological
difference is the number one thing i
work with people on because unless you
expand your identity you're gonna
basically keep where you are you might
improve a little or not you might go up
and down a bit but you're gonna stay
within a realm if you're gonna have an
explosive breakthrough to another level
physically mentally financially
spiritually then we gotta not only give
you the tools
we gotta shift that internal sense of
who you really are and have you find
that you are more than anything that's
ever happened to you that you can handle
whatever shows up even if it's
incredibly scary or uncomfortable rule
number four change your psychology the
difference between making it or not is
psychology and skill
you need both and honestly skill is the
smaller of the two
i'm going to give you a ton of
strategies this week i'm going to do
psychology first and you're going to see
why as this day goes by because you're
going to discover when people stand up
and we figure out what's the choke hold
on their business 80 percent of the time
it's going to be their psychology
the choke hold on the growth of your
business is the psychology and skills of
the leader
period
that's it
and if we change those two things skills
too
marketing skills financial intelligence
recruiting training all those things
between those two don't get me wrong we
got to do the skills also but i could
give you every skill how many of you
learned before that was invaluable from
some source a mentor a coach an event a
university i don't know what and you
were excited about it and then you never
actually follow through who's done this
before say i
listen knowledge is not power
execution trumps knowledge every day of
the week
my goals make you execute i can't make
you but i can get you when you tap into
that part of yourself and that shift is
the most important shift of these few
days also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five feed your mind i
developed this little system and the
system was really simple and i tell
people now as i say number one every
single day you got to feed and
strengthen your mind
until you do that you're always going to
be in fear because fear is automatic the
human brain is designed for survival
it's not designed for success your brain
is not designed to make you happy that's
your job right the only way you're going
to do it is if you feed your mind
because otherwise weeds grow
automatically by drinking my coach
mentor jim rohney's telling me so tony
every day you got to stand guard at the
door of your mind you got to watch
what's going on because if you're not
careful stuff will go in he said not all
the times is somebody who cares about
you he said you know if you're your
family yeah if your worst enemy puts
sugar in your coffee he said what
happens i said you got sweet coffee
because we're your best friend by
accident or your family
don't mean to they drop one drop of
strychnine on your coffee you're dead he
said so life sugar and strychnine and
watch your coffee right right so every
day i decided i i'm old enough honestly
there was no internet those days i'm
pretty ancient i used to go to the
library because the only patient go and
i would i read biographies i'd read
people's lives and it make me go wait a
second as bad as i think it is the
greatest people in the world had it
worse sure so there's something here so
you feed your mind i i'm jim rohn you
say to me
skip a meal but don't skip reading said
read 30 minutes a day i don't give a
damn what it is today i don't mean
internet crap i mean
read something a biography read
something that's a strategy read
something's gonna change your life rule
number six unlock your own true nature
all of us
we could take our work
and think of work as being like a gift i
personally believe
that one of the greatest gifts outside
my love that i can give another human
being is my labor but there's three
gifts of labor you might have within
your nature meaning
you can master anything but under stress
people tend to go back to their true
nature
and there are three gifts of labor that
you can give
one of those gifts we might call the
gift of being an artist
or a talent or another word for it be a
truly skilled producer
some people the reason you know this is
your gift is what you love to do is to
create a product or service and deliver
it to people and you're enamored by that
the woman over here who is doing the
work if you recall you know in hospice
she would be a perfect example of an
artist she's not in it she wants to make
money don't get me wrong but she would
never trade the money for the impact
so when someone is in it as an artist
and by the way most businesses are
started by artists
there's somebody who is an amazing
negotiator an amazing fashion designer
amazing code writer and they said i work
for this company and they don't do a
good job for customers and i can do a
better job i don't work for them and
they start their own company thinking
that the company is all driven just by
the sales or the negotiation or the code
or the fashion but a company is much
more complex than that especially as it
grows
so an artist is in it for the impact
and yes they want to make money don't
get me wrong but it's not the first
thing and they won't trade it when i
talk to artists about selling their
business they look at me like i'm trying
to sell their child
the second gift you might have
is the gift of being a manager leader
a manager leader is someone who lives to
manage people and processes they love to
figure out how to maximize a business by
changing the gears creating a new
process working with people and those
people love it now they are not artists
in that their talent or skill they're
not there delivering it directly to the
client they want to work on the people
that directly respond they want to work
on the system that makes this business
work and so they think it differently
they're inspired by different things
they make different decisions
is one better or worse than the other
yes or no
no they're just different and by the way
you might say i have both those skills i
bet you do but they're not equal
because they're different types of
skills so you might have them both
but there's one that is your true nature
that when things are going well you're
going to go back to it when things are
really up you're going to go back to it
under stress and under excitement we
return to our nature by the way a great
company can't be great without great
artists talent who really deliver
extraordinary products or services a
company cannot maintain greatness and
grow unless they have some great manager
leaders who can run remind the process
and the people they're both critical
components the third
choice of service the true gift you can
give is that of an entrepreneur
and while most of you in this room will
call yourself an entrepreneur and you
would be entrepreneurial
by this definition it's a little
different most people think of an
entrepreneur as anybody starts multiple
businesses no that's not true
some artists are multiple businesses
because they want to get all kinds of
things for all kinds of people some
managers want to do multiple businesses
so they feel like they have multiple
systems but entrepreneurs in it for one
thing
the juice of risk
they want to make money
and by the way an entrepreneur will they
sell this business yes or no
for the right price they'll sell
anything and their mindset is get sell
it i'll start another one sell it i'll
buy another one
they are not attached they might enjoy
the product service they might be proud
of their product or service but they're
in it for the risk and they're the kind
of person that when they lose massively
they jump up dust themselves off and
want to do it again rule number seven
use pain to grow why is it that we often
wait to experience pain
before we decide to change a part of our
lives make a different choice to create
a shift why is it that we wait so often
for stress impressions i have that
question was burning me because you know
i was traveling around had the privilege
of this stage of life you know traveling
around the earth
people from every walk of life right 100
plus countries i've worked in and i'd
see the same problems even though you
mean different cultures like you know
going to an asian culture it's not about
the individual it's about the group
right but i'd still see the same
problems and then i got obsessed with it
like okay what what's the common human
experience because i'm seeing the same
problems even though it's a different
culture even those different beliefs
right and i began to realize that there
are certain human needs and there are
six that identify that i've used ever
since and it's helped me understand and
so one of those needs is certainty and
it's the base human need certainty that
you can avoid pain and that you can be
comfortable is the most basic need it's
a survival need because if you have
continuous pain that's continuous damage
continuous damage equals death right
but what happens for people is most
people
that first basic need is where they live
they don't grow
another need the second need is
uncertainty because ironically if you're
certain all the time you're bored out of
your mind if you're completely uncertain
you're kind of freaked out and a balance
is not it it's the ability to use both
enter both worlds and then there's the
need for significance which is a big
part of our culture today thanks to
social media
that need to feel special unique
important right it can be a very
positive emotion or need it can be very
negative depending upon how it's used
how it's directed and then there's the
need for connection and love which
everybody has and those four needs
everybody finds a way to meeting if you
have to lie to yourself work 20-hour
days you're going to find certainty
somehow you're going to find where i
variety you're going to find some form
of significance some people do it by
tearing other people down some people do
it by working harder you know it's
different you're going to find some
level of at least connection if not love
but the final two what make people feel
alive which is growing everything in the
universe grows or dies and contributing
everything is in the universe
contributes or it's eventually
eliminated by evolution so those are the
spiritual needs growth and contribution
where you get beyond yourself and i
think that the majority of us don't take
moves because of fear and fear is just
uncertainty it's that base need and when
i go around and i describe this in more
detail and i work with a big audience 15
20 000 people and i'll say how to do a
set of exercises and have them figure
out where do they get what triggers them
to be certain or uncertain what triggers
them a variety and so forth so they
understand that like everything i do is
to meet these needs
but then i get them to say what are your
top two not what you think they should
be not what you want them to be what are
they and 90 of the people in our culture
our certainty and significance or
significance and certainty even though
they really want love
so they have this route like if i can be
successful enough then i'll be worthy of
it or if i can just control it enough
and know it's that way but you can't
control love right and so most people
are
they're trying to meet their needs in a
kind of a backwards way
and i think that that fear that
uncertainty is what keeps most people
going until they get enough pain and
then that pushes them through a
threshold where their needs aren't being
met they got to change and unfortunately
most people wait till they have enough
pain i that's not my preference rule
number eight do what makes you feel
alive ultimately i really believe
that the
probably the most i don't know the most
sacred thing in our lives that we can
give another human being besides our
love is our labor
you think about it your labor is your
energy it's your time it's your emotion
it's your intellect it's your spirit to
some extent and if you can find a way
where
what you do for a living activates that
sense of what you're made for then work
is not work whether you be in fiji or
whether you be in a an environment that
might be seen less exciting and
promising in the moment trust me i've
worked in plenty of those too but with
the same level of excitement and passion
because i found what
turns me on that makes me feel alive
makes me feel like i'm doing something
that's worthwhile and on labor day i
think a lot of people it's just a
holiday to get away and take time off of
labor
and my hope is to trigger you to think
about how could you turn your labor into
your love i think it was uh mark twain
who said when your vocation becomes your
vacation that's when life becomes truly
magnificent and i'm privileged enough to
have that but i pursued it and one of
the secrets that i found and i know you
know this in your soul is that we all
know if you're going to be masterful at
something you don't show up you know as
the best in the world at something you
don't show up in environments that you
want to be in you get there because you
did things for thousands and thousands
of hours most of you know the concept of
mastery taking 10 000 hours that's an
arbitrary number but i'm sure you've
heard about you want to get really good
at something it's 10 000 hours because
when you do something enough with enough
intensity enough intention to constantly
get better when your labor is your love
and where your labor is something you
have to always get better at
then usually what happens is you get
these insights that allow you to serve
more but i also think that labor you
know talking about this weekend what
makes people fulfilled by their labor is
is their motives for it if your motive
is just to make money or just to pay
your bills or
or just to get rich or whatever you
think that's going to be those people
never really are fulfilled even if they
make the money um the most fulfilled
human beings in my experience and i've
had the privilege of working with
literally four million people from 125
countries now around the world the
people that are most alive regardless of
the economics are people that have found
something that they really feel the
motive is more than just themselves
you know we all know what it feels like
when you're trying to do so for
something for someone you love and
you're not doing it as a trade you're
not trying to get something back you're
just doing it because it's what you're
made for and
i always tell people motive does matter
that if you're just doing something for
yourself there's nothing wrong with that
because
life supports whatever else supports
life if you're part of life and you're
trying to do something it's going to
make your life better i think the
universe god whatever proper term for
you whatever your belief system is
you know
infinite intelligence gets connected to
you and it gives you insights
but i think if you're trying to serve
more than yourself more life than just
you
when things support more of life more of
life shows up to support you and that
might sound kind of airy fairy but it's
my experience you know when you're
trying to support your family when
suddenly i had four kids three of them
overnight
my life changed my intellect changed my
abilities changed because i was trying
to serve something more than just me
when i started really focusing how to
serve a community and then a country and
then humanity as corny as it may sound
um you get insights you won't get when
you're just trying to somehow you know
make your labor happen or get the job
done so
labor could be love and it isn't for
most people most people i think are
unhappy in their life because they look
at
labor as work uh they look at as why
should i have to effort so much and in
my experience effort is the reward if
you are doing something you love it's
there so if you don't have it you might
say tony that's all wonderful you're in
fiji and you do what you love and i
don't have that thanks so much for
giving me the lecture
i'm not coming from that place i'm come
from the place of saying you can
discover something that you're really
passionate about but in order to do it
you got to get out of the story of what
you can't do and you've got to put
yourself on the line rule number nine
trade your expectations for appreciation
here is the secret to ending your
suffering
trade your expectations
for appreciation and your whole life
will change in that moment the minute
you appreciate something your suffering
is gone it's just your expectations that
are stressing you out and sometimes
not meeting your expectations will cause
you to come up with a new way to grow a
new way to do something that's better
than what you did before
what would your life be like
if you made this decision today for real
screw everything else got a million
other things we're going to do to
improve your life what if you really
made a real decision i am not suffering
anymore life is too short to suffer i'm
gonna live in a beautiful state i'm
gonna have a good time every day no
matter what i'm gonna catch myself i
know i'll get off target for a minute
but i'll catch it and get right back in
a beautiful state the minute you stop
complaining about your kids but you look
at the things you love in them
the minute you stop complaining about
your partners and you think about what's
a better way to get through them this is
a chance for me to grow and expand the
minute you appreciate anything your
suffering is over because loss less and
never is always a lie you don't lose
something you gain a new option you
aren't in a place where you can never do
it again except when you believe that
because whatever you believe you're
going to live a new set of appreciations
and suffering is over
remember there's an old phrase says
don't sweat the small stuff and the
second rule is it's all small stuff
right what would life be like if all the
things you get frustrated by or stressed
about or worried about if you just
wouldn't indulge in them anymore if you
started to you catch it within 30
seconds or less and snap out and find
yourself focusing on something you can
appreciate or something you'd love
or something you're grateful for or
someone you love if you were to train
your mind and heart and body to live in
a beautiful state every day no matter
what how much more magnificent would
your life be how much more joy would
fill your body because when you're
grateful
suffering disappears doesn't it
you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously they don't go together
every problem is temporary
only your soul is permanent and number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is make progress when you
look at what makes people really feel
alive there's very few things that
compete with growing and of course
giving
and where does growth come from first of
all without it life feels pretty dead
inside we're all trying to mark
something that gives us a sense of
aliveness people ask me all the time
what does it really take to be happy too
i can give it to you one word progress
progress equals happiness did you ever
achieve a goal and after you achieve it
said is this all there is so you got to
think to yourself why don't they stay
happy i'm like i work so hard at this
why does that stay fulfilled because
life is not about you just getting your
goals my teacher gymnastics you say
something it was so profound when i was
17 years old he said what you get will
never make you happy it doesn't matter
what you get who you become that'll make
you very happy or very sad
see ultimately we have challenges so
that we can grow and we have growth so
we have something to give and it's the
giving that makes us feel alive and the
growing that makes us feel alive and so
if you don't grow consciously here's the
challenge part life will show up and
give you something to grow from and
success fulfillment aliveness is not one
thing you did one time it's all the
little things it's saying i love you
it's stepping up it's doing what's right
even when no one else rewards you those
little things are the things that make
you grow and that growth is what makes
you feel alive listen there's only one
really static clause in the universe
everything grows or it dies
and everything ultimately contributes or
it's eliminated by evolution if nothing
else so the imperative for you and i is
to understand that growth isn't always
easy in fact the easy stuff really makes
you grow
listen there is no failure as long as
you learn something because that
learning leads to growth that growth
leads to something where you can build
something create something or give
something to yourself others your family
or to have something that's meaningful
so where are you not growing that you
can make some progress on this week just
tackle one thing is it your body is it
your relationship is it your level of
happiness that's growth just to find
happiness or joy or meaning in difficult
situations those types of progresses
will lead to an extraordinary quality of
life
[Music]
grow or die how's that for an uplifting
message
one way you'll know you're growing is
when things that used to be big seem
little to you give yourself 20 30
minutes every day listen to something
that inspires you or read a book
something with philosophy or strategy
that can improve the quality of your
life your career your family your
happiness your joy something because
great ideas have to be pursued answers
don't interrupt you they have to be
pursued and if they're pursued with
enough without focus enough caring
enough compassion enough drive you'll
find answers that'll help you to grow
and if you don't life's going to
challenge you anyway so why not push
yourself out there with some new goals
some new desires that you proactively
create that stimulate the growth that
make you fulfilled and instead of
expecting the joy lasts forever just
know life is progress baby growth is
everything growth will give you more to
give and as you give more you'll love
more you'll love yourself you'll love
your life and you'll be a source of
generous loves to others
you are where you are in life and
business because of your standards it's
just not important enough for you yet to
hit that next level for you for me for
all of us we've settled we've settled
for what currently is and haven't
demanded from ourselves that we reach
that next level change your standards
change your life
so i was recently talking to alex on my
team
and he helps me run toronto dance also
the largest dance school for salsa in
north america probably and he recently
went through this weight loss challenge
and he lost i don't know i want to say
30 pounds and now he's sticking to this
really thin line of between 150 and 155
pounds that's his goal that's his
standard when he's when he's getting
close to 155 he slows down on the eating
and when he's around 150 he has a little
bit more and he's constantly staying in
this band because he set a new standard
for himself even though he might have
been 180 or 185 before
now anywhere close to 155 is gonna be
too much like that's it that's my new
standard that's the lowest i'm gonna go
which is crazy high compared to what he
was before he's now trying to bring that
same standard to his business so what
he's trying to do every day now if you
follow him on instagram is he's posting
at the end of the day how proud he is of
the effort he put in
how proud is he of the effort that he
put in out of ten and sometimes you see
it's 5.5 sometimes you see it's a seven
and every now and then it's an eight or
even a nine
how proud he is of the effort that he
put in this is now the area where he
needs to raise his standards and i was
talking to him yesterday and a big
breakthrough that happened was said alex
you lost 30 pounds man or more from your
weight loss journey now the idea of
being over 155 is crazy when you used to
be 180 right or 185 it's crazy you need
to take that same approach to your
business to your effort that you're
proud of yourself every day for what
you're doing anything under eight
should be considered a cheat day
anything under eight
is like you had a cheat day on your diet
every now and then on his weight loss
journey he had a cheat day he had a
moment of weakness he he went for a
giant pizza and a cake because he was
starving and he couldn't control himself
but it was these one-off moments right
it was like once every three weeks or
something and he continued down
that now needs to be your daily effort
if it's under eight that's like you're
eating cake and pizza
it needs to be the new water line if
you're getting close to it's like holy
cow i can't i need to work harder i need
to accomplish i need to go off and do
just like 155 now is that benchmark for
himself and putting into those terms
made sense for him because he had higher
standards now for himself in what he ate
in how he took care of his body than he
did for what he was doing into his
business and so it's the same thing for
you you want to grow you want to get
better you want to improve you have to
raise your standards
you have to now not settle for where
you're at because where you're at is
good this is the problem good is the
enemy of great right where you're at is
good it's good it's not amazing but it
doesn't suck because if it sucked if you
hated it every day you would have to
find a way out but because it's good you
don't do it you don't change
it's not important enough for you to
want to get to that next step that's
what i want to force in this video i'm
going to give you three ways to do it
step number one is understand where do
you need to have a higher standard where
in your life do you need to have a
higher standard what's the thing that
you want
more of alex did it in his health and
his weight now he's applying to his
business and his life for you where is
it is it your health is it your business
is it learning the skill set is it
posting content every day like where is
it that you need to have a higher center
for yourself be specific be clear write
it down step number two is surround
yourself with it daily one of the
greatest things that you need to do that
really helps you raise your standards is
be around people who are more high
achieving in that thing
be around people who are more high
achieving in the thing that you want to
get great at the thing that you are weak
at
so
if i was hanging around bodybuilders all
day i probably work out a lot more
right because everybody's doing it
because they have a higher standard
where i might let myself off the hook
for not doing a workout i'm going to see
them crushing it they're gonna lift me
up they'll just have to they'll lift me
up and i'm gonna make them believe in
themselves more that's just gonna happen
i was on twitch streaming last night
league of legends and a guy said man
you're so positive twitch is such a
negative toxic place and you're here
spreading positivity like yeah and i'll
keep doing it and no matter no matter
who comes in who's negative and toxic
i am more confident in my positivity and
belief than you are in your negativity
and toxicity and so i will make you
doubt yourself
because of my confidence whoever's more
confident wins and so the trick is
you're very confident in something and
not so confident in other things the
things that you want to get good at
right things that you want to get great
at the things that you want to get great
at not good things that you want to get
great at
you don't have a high degree of
confidence in your ability to do it
you need to be around people who have a
high degree of confidence and are doing
it whether that's actually face to face
but it could be through videos it could
be through books it could be through
podcasts if you are trying to get
healthy you're trying to lose weight
you're trying to gain strength and
you're following people on instagram and
watching videos that motivate you every
day it's in your environment every day
it will it will just pull you up my
videos my channels i use for myself
because it makes me feel more believed i
surround myself with tony robbins every
day and steve jobs every day in kanye
west every day and oprah winfrey every
day they're in my ear they're in my ear
they're pulling me up and they can do
that for you as well so whatever it is
you want to raise your standard in
surround yourself every day with that
content with those people and then step
number three is schedule for success the
mindset is the first part but then you
got to do something you want to
accomplish a new level amazing what are
you going to do every day show me in
your calendar pull out your calendar
pull out your you know week to week from
this sunday until the next sunday seven
days in between what are you gonna do
show me in your calendar where you're
spending time developing this new habit
fixing your new mindset putting the
actual work in you want to gain muscle
awesome it's great to be around people
who are doing it but then you have to
actually put in your calendar i'm going
to go to the gym i'm going to start
lifting some weights you want to create
youtube content amazing it's great maybe
to be inspired watching me or other
youtube creators but nothing happens
until you pick up your phone and you
start filming something and then it has
to be in your calendar if you hope for
something to happen it's not it's not
going to happen
if you hope for something to happen it's
not going to happen
right
this is something that you have a
slipping standard on you know you want
to get better at and so it has to be in
your calendar you have to schedule for
success this is what new success looks
like for you great your success is your
habits so schedule it in that every week
or every day or every month however
often you need to do it it's in there
it's happening you're gonna raise your
standards because of it because you made
it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you're special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent one-on-one with tony robbins
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there precision
medicine billionaires know about it but
the average person doesn't what pushed
me over the edge recently
is i had some experiences that really
hit me hard when the accident was so
severe
that the prognosis was that my career
was over